started at ESPN in 1991 that means he
was working there five years before I
even got there and I led into a
countless amounts of inside the Huddle's
and Sports Center Chris Mortensen dick
McCann Award winner he's in the Pro
Football Hall of Fame people he's here
on the Rich Eisen show hi how are you
Mort doing well rich you enjoyed I
actually went to the combine you know I
had missed the previous two combines for
a guy who who when I think my first one
I went to was 87 and sexy where I met
well there's very few people left around
from that time but it was interesting
coming back this year and being able to
physically do it still in the cancer
journey that's what I called it's a
journey and but I'm doing well
thankful for each day and in the you
know looking forward to the draft and
obviously free agency and all that's
going on in the NFL which is a
significant amount yeah we look at all
the trades we've already had there that
are not official yet but will become
official and then certainly ready for
the free agency and and and the draft
has always been one of my favorite
events so let's start off with the foals
of it all what do you think the market
is for him how interested do you think
the Eagles are in trading him walk me
through the process as we are Friday
before the new league year Morton I
think this is dangerous territory for
Howie Roseman I I think there's a
overwhelming sense within the Eagles
organization is maybe we ought to say
he's not available
but when teams have inquired and even
know you could say making loose offer
involving a second-round pick the basic
answer was that a we got a first and a
fourth for Sam Bradford and Nick Foles
it is the Super Bowl MVP something Sam
never did so our conversation doesn't
even start without a first and a fourth
and you can expect more that's their way
of saying we really don't want to trade
him and oh by the way they shouldn't
trade him there's no guarantee Carson
Wentz is going to be back in September
and there's also you know listen Carson
has said he's going to he's going to
play the same style of football he's
always played you know zetas which is
pretty
you know athletic some could say
reckless but it's athletic so you know
you've got a Super Bowl team kind of in
the circle to repeat why would you trade
Nick Foles
so that's why it would be you know if
you're listening it in your alley
Roseman you say what you what you told
teams really I expect nobody to meet
that price so so somebody knocks on the
door and says look Sam Bradford was a
one in a four because Minnesota was
desperate
I mean they had a Super Bowl team ready
go and and they're their franchise face
their quarterback of their future has a
freak accident in practice and they had
a put Humpty Dumpty back together again
last second we just want to knock on a
door for your quarterback here's the
second-round pick yes that's not the
Eagles problem yeah he says no to that I
mean you know listen they're gonna
they're gonna gain extra drafting so
they got that 30-second pick on the
draft that that's actually a pretty
valuable spot to be at in other words
there could be some people coming to
number 32 at the end of the first night
because the value that pick has and pick
up I'm not gonna say they pick up a
second-round pick but they'll pick up
some extra picks though probably gets
upland for Vinny curry a defensive
lineman
that now is kind of a spare part but an
expensive one with Michael Bennett trade
going down so no I mean I think for Nick
Foles yeah and the desperate part it's
just it's just part of mine is are you
comfortable with Nate sub-field being
your backup quarterback and they like
Nate knowing that they say Carson
doesn't play the first three game and
saying saying what if that happens if he
gets grander late in a year you're gonna
say because we couldn't resist a
second-round pick
for Nick Foles we blew a chance it's
repeating as a Super Bowl champion or
even a chance to make that run I I think
it's dangerous but I have no doubt
listen the Arizona Cardinals don't even
have a quarterback on the roster do they
that's kind of desperation mm-hmm
interesting Chris Mortensen here on the
Rich Eisen show what's the cousins of it
all where do you think Kirk fits into it
I know he tweeted out that he's open to
all-comers but
the general sense is why would he go to
a spot where he's got a build when there
are some more ready-made situations for
him what can you tell me more well I
think that the listen I've always
thought the Vikings were probably the
favorite they have enough salary cap
space about fifty million dollars in
caps cap space which is which is really
more than 50 million so in that team as
we know is ready to make a run at the
same time the New York Jets could do
something what people would say is give
him stupid money and some people and it
makes it make these selfish that we are
a lot closer than you think
and the NFC is a lot more competitive
conference which it is and whereas the
AFC is not so if all of a sudden they're
offering Kirk Cousins 33 million dollars
guaranteed a year and they can convince
them persuade him that that this is a
more competitive team and you will make
it so now we got Denver who doesn't have
as much money but they can argue that
they know you would you would help us
you'd plug it in and the Arizona
Cardinals they are going to dispatch
once again I believe where he
Fitzgerald's already done it once so I
think Larry Fitzgerald is also going to
get very involved in actively recruiting
right there but I would leave I would
handicap toises Vikings won a Jets 1b
and Broncos third on that list Chris
Mortensen Chris Mortensen of ESPN is
gonna be part of the whole worldwide
leader SportsCenter free agency
extravaganza next Wednesday here on the
Rich Eisen show okay Mort so what is
going on in Seattle total rebuild is
that what's going on yeah it's a roster
rebuild and I think in a way they've you
know maybe it's changing chemistry and
by the way team chemistry I think is an
underrated thing and maybe there's
something there or there's certainly
older players who are getting injuries
and Richard Sherman is among them
obviously and you know we saw the New
Orleans Saints do something last year
where they Sean Payton like made over
half his coaching staff people that he
were guys he was close to and made over
the good portion of the roster and the
results were significant I think Seattle
kind of looked at that and said you know
we're at that point we need to
the same thing and in order to try and
take the next step we seem to make
changes we didn't expect on their
coaching staff and now certainly with
the roster and I think that you know we
expect Richard Sherman to be released
later today who knows there could be
another surprise or two from them as we
go forward and when it all comes down to
it with Dez Bryant the Cowboys how does
that play out well you know this I
really think that there is a strong
sentiment in the building that something
has to happen with this salary and and
and then there's one person who stands
above all as you know it was Jerry Jones
who has this fondness to basically not
let go of the people that he cares about
significantly and that's where Steven
Jones comes in
so yes exactly so it's really I think
the feeling is he's got to take a pay
cut or that you know in order for us to
continue to build this roster we've got
to get him down in salary and we'll just
take it I I think I think it's a bubble
thing even though Jerry said he expects
them to be there
bubble sing meaning like it's 50/50
50/50 could go either way does that
happen before you know free agency it I
don't know but I do know that I've been
told that something has to happen with
Dez and his contract couple wins
yeah with Dez well which exactly Dez
knocking he doesn't want any part of
that I mean he doesn't want any pot if
you went on the open market what do we
think he's gonna get yes I know no he
probably would not get what he's getting
I understand that but he's also just
strikes me as a very prideful guy that
might sit there and say the reason why
his numbers aren't as great as they used
to be is not any fault of his correct so
that would be that that one it
definitely keeps bears in mind for us to
keep an eye on is there anything going
on with Brees and the Saints we should
know about because if there's no if
there's no contract between now and no
Wednesday it's possible he hits the open
market right yes and by the way he can
talk to teams like it's like an
unrestricted free agent during the legal
you call it a tampering period but it's
really legal negotiation
period now you know but a new race has
no desire to hit the open market I mean
so basically if you're the agent for
Drew Brees it's Tom Condon yeah you know
you would love to take you out in the
open margins and and and go to the
Minnesota Vikings and say how much would
he pay drew but Drew Brees wants to be a
saint the Saints want him to be there
and I expect him to be a saint okay last
one for you Mort when you said you're on
a journey here what we through it how
are you doing I mean what how are you
able to stay as involved as you are in
the NFL and still focus on your
healthier well it's I think maybe I'm
taking better care of myself than ever
before but the the journey is obviously
I went through the through the the
throat you know cancer thing that's
doing well it metastasized to my lungs
that's not the ideal but you know what
they're they're doing wonderful within
research and the drugs I'm taking for
the tumors in my lung or responding and
stabilized and you know you just see
well you sleep and you know you wake up
and you got today I mean listen our good
friend Jim Kelly or we weren't broken
over this would happen to him yeah and
that's why image imitate is the same
thing even when he was declared
cancer-free I don't think anybody who
gets declared cancer-free I think they
understand you know you're never
cancer-free it's the journey but it's
for Jim you know really uh I'm more
focused on Jim than I am me I'm thankful
for today and I'm doing well Mort you
sound great I got to be honest with you
sound the same it's great well I don't
know I don't know if that's true but
when people tell me when people tell me
I look good I always tell them check
your glasses now yes let's be real come
on a Mort love chat when you miss
chatting with you great chatting Lea I
really appreciate the time rich thanks a
lot man thanks for all you do for for
everybody charities the st. Jude saying
you know we need people like you who are
willing to go out there and be a leader
in that net territory thank you yeah
Mort thank you you're the best really
appreciate it take care you got to act
Mort report and again check more doubt
on the worldwide leader next Wednesday
they have a spa
Center special and I'll be on NFL
Network at the same time we're
competitors in that regard but we are
colleagues first and foremost the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience